Traduttore: Michele Gianella
Revisore: Valerio Burragato
Quante volte avete sentito parlare
di “onda tecnologica”?
È quello di cui io mi occupo.
Ma è curioso perché
ogni volta che sento questo termine,
io non posso fare a meno
di pensare alle onde dell’oceano.
Tra gli sport che pratico, infatti,
il surf è decisamente il mio preferito
e anche se non è sempre quello
in cui ho i migliori risultati,
se c’è una cosa che ho imparato
è che, quando sei lì in mezzo all’oceano
e sta arrivando un’onda
di due o tre metri,
puoi fare solo due cose.
Evitarla, spostandoti
dal suo punto di rottura.
Per farlo devi remare sulla tavola,
e vi garantisco che prima o poi
le braccia si stancano,
l’onda arriva e ti porta
via con sé, dove vuole.
Oppure puoi provare
a trasformare quell’onda
nella cosa più straordinaria
che esista sulla faccia della Terra,
e cavalcarla.
Per riuscirci non bastano
fortuna o doti innate,
ma servono studio ed esercizio.
Studio, per conoscere la baia,
le sue correnti, i suoi venti,
per conoscere il funzionamento delle maree
e saper scegliere la tavola migliore
da usare in quelle condizioni.
Ed esercizio perché
è solo stando immersi nell’oceano
che imparerete a capire quale sarà
il punto di rottura dell’onda,
il momento giusto per alzarvi sulla tavola
e quale sarà l’onda migliore
da provare a cavalcare.
E quando parliamo di onda tecnologica,
le regole sono le stesse.
Possiamo fuggire oppure cavalcare l’onda:
e lo possiamo fare
con studio ed esercizio.
Studio in questo caso significa studio
della società presente, dei suoi valori,
delle tecnologie
e delle loro potenzialità;
ed esercizio significa
immaginare e immergersi nel futuro,
per imparare a capire
quando arriverà l’onda
del cambiamento tecnologico,
che tipo di impatti avrà,
e quale sia il modo migliore
per cavalcarla nella giusta direzione.
A proposito di direzione,
vi ricordate quando,
per andare da qualche parte,
usavamo le cartine?
Sembrano passati secoli.
Eppure è stato solo nel 2000
che Bill Clinton ha aperto all’uso civile
la tecnologia del GPS,
trasformando le cartine
in navigatori satellitari
e dopo qualche anno
in app nel nostro smartphone
che non solo ci indicano la strada,
ma ci consigliano anche
quella con meno traffico.
Tra qualche anno tutto questo
sarà solo un ricordo,
perché non saremo più noi
a interagire con queste tecnologie,
che parleranno direttamente con gli
algoritmi alla guida dei nostri veicoli.
A San Francisco e in altre città
auto così sono già per le strade.
E la Tesla model 3, che uscirà nel 2018,
non solo sarà elettrica
e dotata di software di guida autonoma
ma la potremo comprare
per soli 35.000 dollari.
Si parla tantissimo
di queste auto, e a ragione:
c’è chi dice che saranno 128
le cose che scompariranno
con questa innovazione:
non avremo più bisogno
di cartelli stradali, targhe, guidatori.
Io dico che i cambiamenti
saranno molti di più
perché tecnologie così impattano
anche su ambiti che non le
riguardano direttamente.
Ed è questo quello che io intendo
con onda tecnologica:
una tecnologia così potente
da essere in grado
di cambiare completamente
tutte le regole del gioco, della società
e della vita di tutti i giorni.
Possiamo paragonarla a uno tsunami,
che non ammette la possibilità
di scappare o di essere contenuto,
ma che con lo studio e l’esercizio
diventa cavalcabile
e può portarci verso lidi meravigliosi.
Ed è per questo che è così importante
studiare queste tecnologie,
che al giorno d’oggi arrivano
a una velocità tale
per cui se mancano lo studio e l’esercizio
diventano anche difficili da percepire.
Parliamo di intelligenza artificiale,
robotica, stampa 3D,
parliamo di genetica,
biotecnologie, nanotecnologie,
parliamo di fonti di energia pulita
innovative e di blockchain.
Tecnologie così potenti
da essere in grado di impattare
su ogni aspetto della nostra vita,
rivoluzionandolo.
E immergersi nel futuro e studiarlo
diventa un esercizio
non solo utile, ma anche necessario
per capire il presente
e decidere in quale direzione andare.
E più ci penso,
più nasce e cresce dentro di me
un senso di urgenza.
Urgenza di fare qualcosa, di dirlo a tutti
e di conoscere l’opinione degli altri.
Ed è proprio dal confronto,
e grazie all’aiuto
di un gruppo di visionari
che la pensa come me,
è nata Impactscool.
Un’organizzazione che mette
a disposizione di tutti, gratuitamente,
formazione, dibattito
e collaborazione su questi temi.
Solo nel 2017 abbiamo già lavorato
con oltre 1.000 studenti,
in 14 università
di 2 diversi paesi europei
ed entro fine anno
saranno almeno il triplo
e saremo già presenti
in diversi continenti.
Il prossimo step sono le scuole
e tutti quei luoghi
dove ci sia qualcuno
che abbia voglia di prendere
parte alla discussione.
Portiamo per mano le persone nel futuro,
lavorando con workshop
che permettono di immergersi
in scenari probabili
e di discuterne le implicazioni.
E, perché no, costruiamo
anche insieme scenari migliori.
Ad esempio, lavoriamo in classe
con un caso come questo:
Robbie è un robot dotato
di intelligenza artificiale.
È molto carino,
ma è anche straordinariamente avanzato.
Tanto che è in grado
di assistere in tutto e per tutto Maria,
una signora anziana
e non più autosufficiente.
Lo sapete che sono circa un milione
gli italiani che dedicano
la propria giornata
a prendersi cura di un parente?
Robbie può portare un enorme sollievo
nella vita di queste persone.
E in quella di Maria,
restituendole autonomia e dignità.
Si potrebbe obiettare
che non sia giusto togliere a Maria
il tocco umano di un parente.
Ma se Robbie fosse anche
un’ottima compagnia?
Se le permettesse di restare più attiva
e trascorrere il tempo
in modo più divertente,
ad esempio sfidandola a carte?
Sì, perché Robbie
ha impresso nel suo codice
l’obiettivo di massimizzare
il benessere di Maria.
E per raggiungerlo
farebbe tutto il possibile.
E Maria lo sa,
e pur essendo un po’ sovrappeso
riesce a convincerlo
che la cosa che la rende più felice
sia mangiare cioccolata fondente.
A ben pensarci, io sono convinta
che mia nonna lo avrebbe convinto
a comprarle una stecca
di sigarette al giorno.
E allora, cosa dovrebbe fare Robbie
in questa situazione?
E che diritti avrebbe
se Maria dovesse maltrattarlo
per averle negato la cioccolata?
Può sembrarvi qualcosa di molto lontano,
ma a gennaio il Parlamento Europeo
ha sottolineato l’urgenza
di creare un quadro normativo
che regoli le responsabilità
e i diritti dei robot,
dando loro lo status
di Electronic Personhood.
In classe lavoriamo
con questo e altri temi
che sono molto più attuali
di quanto pensiamo.
Il nostro compito è quello
di accendere la miccia.
Far nascere il dibattito, il dubbio.
Ma soprattutto è quello di fare esercizio.
Esercizio del nostro spirito critico,
della nostra capacità di collaborare,
esercizio di creatività
e immersione nel futuro.
Queste capacità sono state
la chiave della nostra evoluzione
fin dai tempi dell’Homo Sapiens.
Sono alla base della nostra umanità,
ed è arrivato il momento
di rimetterle al centro.
E allora, perché non le
esercitiamo quotidianamente
a scuola, al lavoro, in famiglia?
Non sono forse il libero arbitrio
e la capacità di immaginare il futuro
- permettendoci di cacciare, ad esempio,
animali molto più grandi di noi -
che ci hanno permesso di sopravvivere
ed evolverci nei millenni?
Accendiamo la miccia, dicevo.
E a volte,
questa miccia si trasforma
in veri e propri incendi
e riusciamo a trasmettere
quel famoso senso di urgenza
che è all’origine della nostra attività.
E allora succede qualcosa di magico:
gruppi di persone che partecipano
appassionatamente al dibattito,
lavorano insieme
e scelgono di far diventare
la nostra missione anche la loro,
organizzando a loro volta
workshop in tutto il mondo.
Stiamo creando una community
che possa non solo
studiare ed esercitarsi,
ma anche collaborare per costruire insieme
un futuro che tenga conto
dei nostri valori
come esseri umani,
come società e come individui.
Ed è proprio dai valori
che dobbiamo ripartire,
un altro elemento fondamentale
della nostra umanità.
Perché oggi, quei valori,
siamo chiamati a scriverli
in un codice che non è più
quello delle leggi o delle religioni.
Siamo chiamati a scriverli in software,
a imprimerli nei prodotti e nei servizi
che usiamo tutti i giorni.
Dobbiamo imprimerli in Robbie
se vogliamo che sia capace
di stare al nostro fianco
e fornirgli gli strumenti
per decidere cosa fare
con Maria e la cioccolata.
E chi produce e programma
queste tecnologie
non può non tenere conto
delle linee guida che nascono
dal lavoro che facciamo nei workshop.
Robbie, le auto autonome
e tutte le altre tecnologie
che arriveranno nel futuro
non sono altro che un’estensione
delle nostre azioni.
Potenziano le nostre capacità,
ed è per questo che siamo chiamati
a scegliere come vogliamo usarli.
Sta solo a noi decidere.
Abbiamo un’enorme responsabilità,
ma anche una straordinaria opportunità
per dimostrare di essere umani.
Lo spirito critico, la capacità
di collaborare e la creatività
sono la parte migliore
della nostra specie.
Insieme possiamo e dobbiamo farne uso
per diventare l’onda inarrestabile
verso il migliore dei futuri possibili.
Grazie.
(Applausi)